here's our starting pitcher what he
featured last year
two seams thinking fastball sits right
around 88 miles per hour we've talked a
lot about the changeup
the big weapon form cutter occasionally
he'll sprinkle in
a curveball 7-4 with a era
last year davey's back to work
good start jack davies
mitch keller he is the budweiser
starting pitcher for the pirates here
this afternoon
good work gets the strikeout
jewel board in front of chris bryant
that one is laced into right field base
hit
half around third he's coming in good at
bat
chris bryant goes the other way knocks
in a run
cubs lead one-nothing jock looking for
his first hit
with a cub uniform hit hard fair ball
tag there rizzo win it's two nothing
moran tapped the base and so a tag play
was on its second and brian was able to
slide in they get
one out and a run scores
now the 2-2 pitch from davies
to perez swing and a miss beautiful
change-up
another strikeout for zach davies
he and half will lead off zach hamp
drives one of the air deep center field
back goes offered
it's got a chance it's gone
get out the tape measure for ian happ
a tremendous home run to dead center
his first of the year and the cubs lead
three to nothing
reynolds strikes out swinging on a
beautiful changeup by davies and that's
out number one
how about that yeah he's uh he's feeling
it right now he's locked in with that
release point with his change up
did he hang on to the base yes he did
alan porter anthony
rizzo doing the splits made the grab
gumby wow
hard hit nice play frazier adam frazier
that was a bullet
he was really upset with himself being
charged with an error in each of the
first two games
okay he really has taken a lot of pride
in his defense especially
in the last couple of years where he's
become the
everyday guy he's not bouncing around
anymore every day
the plate for the most part but it's the
action down so the hitter sees it out of
the hands and here comes a good juicy
heater
gets the swing started no not so fast my
friend
the 78 mile an hour change up dipping
and diving out of the zone
a lot of frustrated pirate hitters here
this afternoon
getting him to swing and miss struck him
out
and there's that change up again
zach davies in control
[Music]
he's punched out five today and the cubs
leading
there's a base hit ryan reynolds who
struck out his first two times
lines the ball the other way one big
swing and it's a one-run game it's only
three nothing how about good things
happening with colin moran
don't you know all the way to county
cork
over the left field wall one big swing
and the bucks are within one
really messes up a pitcher
and evans is safe on the ground ball to
third
he's gonna do it for davies
unraveling a little bit here in the
sixth make quality pitches and a good
try there to polanco just miss
that inside corner
david ross out of the dugout makes the
point to the pen he'll take the baseball
from zach davies
[Applause]
he gets a pretty nice hand his cub debut
he exits with
a lead
hammered down the left field lines bear
ball heading towards the corner
and bryant will stop at second
immediately a man into scoring position
and for kb a single a walk and a hard
hit double
three two game cubs lead but looking to
add on
on the ground and pass evans into left
field i think
it went through his legs and the cubs
lead it four to two run his way into
scoring position
the other way caught throw back to first
pick by rizzo double play
well done he didn't run his way into
scoring position he
ran his way into an out
and the bare hand try but baez will not
be able to pull off a miracle play here
[Applause]
left on left here it is and it's hit to
left
down toward the corner and it'll get
down
rattling off the ivy reynolds will be
held at third it's a double for colin
moran
bucks on the pond with one out
and a ground ball sharply hit into right
field for evans
phillip evans with his third hit today
brings home reynolds it's a one run game
and the tying run is 90 feet away
brothers deals on the ground
can they turn it you bet
rizzo good stretch
and they get out of it anderson here
[Applause]
comes
three and two one out base is empty top
nine good looking
might have been a generous call from
ramon de jesus down a run
on the road with one of the best
closures
in the history of the game out there on
the mound
around shin high ball game cubs win
4-3 the final and the cubs take two of
three
to start the year app goes deep
davies picks up the win 4-3 the final